wait you say with me why me yes we're
still reeling over the fact that
victorious finished before cabby could
happen but let's take a look back at
these love stories even though some are
definitely cuter than others I think
that Evan guy is really dumb for not
seeing how great you are
even Jaden back have their share of cute
moments when they're not fighting like
crazy
although Beck and Jade have the most
focused on relationship on the show we
aren't sure how it actually started
since they were already dating when
Victorious began it's not hard to
imagine them meeting since they go to
the same school it's just kind of
surprising how they'd stayed together so
long considering their constant fighting
the first episode not only established
Beck and Jade as a couple but through
Tori into the mix when she showed up
unaware of their relationship of course
it would have been nice of Beck to fill
her in at some point considering her
flirtatious behavior towards him this
first episode is also where we see
beckon Tori share a smooch for the first
time even if it was only during an
alphabetical improv activity at school
needless to say Jade wasn't exactly fond
of Tori or her improv abilities after
this of course she was mad at Beck - but
that's pretty much the norm with these
two
even though Jaden Beck were together for
most of the show their relationship
definitely had its share of tests it was
just enough to give the Boresha pers
hope that Beck and Tori would end up
together especially when Beck and Jade
started breaking up and getting back
together Jade is furious when she finds
out Beck was hanging out with Elissa
Vaughn and even though he insists
they're just friends Jade unsurprisingly
has an issue with this the two of them
even tried to get Tori in on their
argument but even she can't save them
and Jade ends up dumping back we are
done
Jade breaking up with me almost
immediately Beck starts spending time
with Tori and reveals that he's actually
happy about his breakup with Jade why
because I can't remember the last time
she what nice thing for me yeah the
lesson here is don't get your boyfriend
a can of lemonade for his birthday
but despite Jade's jealousy issues and
Beck feeling unappreciated their breakup
doesn't even last the whole episode
and they get back together after a
scheme involving Tory xrv and an angry
Rottweiler you know a standard
victorious shenanigan
but even though things are back on with
Jade's ex connection with Tory stays
intense in the very next episode Tory
the zombie cat decides to give Tory a
monster makeover that goes wrong when
industrial cement gets involved and Tory
stuck looking like something out of The
Walking Dead but despite her appearance
there's definite chemistry between Tory
and BEC when they appear in a school
play together even playwright Sofia
Michelle loved their performance while
largely ignoring Jaden Robbie's
contributions yeah and did you enjoy my
performance miss Michelle wow I am late
for my plane clearly Tory and Jade
didn't exactly get off on the right foot
but that didn't stop some jory fans from
hoping they'd end up together
this might seem totally out of left
field but it wouldn't be the first time
we saw a love-hate relationship lead to
a romantic one there's Sam and Freddie
from icarly and Josh and Mindy from
Drake and Josh
but sorry Jory fans because these two
never got to be more than friends and
even that took a lot of work on both of
their parts let's take a brief break
from talking about the Bek love triangle
and talk about possibly the most popular
ship on Victorious cabbie seriously how
could anyone hate on this super cute cup
hold fans loved the idea of Kat and
Robby getting together so much that it
even spilled over into the real world
fans were desperate for Ariana Grande
and Matt Bennett to date in real life
and even called them by their couple
named Mariana these two were definitely
cute together behind the scenes but
remained friends and cast mates Kat and
Robby were both kind to each other and
it seemed like their friendship provided
the perfect foundation for a great
relationship during the whole episode
when Kat dated Daniel Robby definitely
seemed jealous about the situation even
though Robby's a little bit on the shy
side he can't hide his feelings for Kat
and even asked her to prom I don't know
if maybe you know you'd want to go to
prom with me unfortunately she said no
because she already had a date but she
seemed to genuinely regret having to
turn down his invitation there are
definitely plenty of bade fans out there
but some victorious viewers think
they're just the worst couple which
is also the name of the episode where
they break up for a second time the two
agreed to take part in sangeun's
gameshow queries for couples but can't
do so without arguing this fight
culminates in a big revelation courtesy
of Bek who's clearly fed up with Jade's
controlling ways even their own friends
can't stand their constant fighting at
this point
Jade walks away and Bek lets her go
unlike their last breakup this one
sticks and they even update their lack
of a relationship on this lab which is
how you know it's serious with Jade and
Bek broken up Tori's big sister Trina
decides to take a chance at pursuing him
well kind of she spreads a rumor that
she and back are dating in order to make
other guys jealous and get them to ask
her out if people think that you're
interested in me then other guys will
want to date me and pretty soon I'll
have boys fighting over me apparently
she didn't learn the lesson from Jade
that jealousy isn't cute in car rain and
fire Trina throws herself quite
literally at Beck to get attention and
he decides to teach her a lesson by
showing her that having a bunch of guys
fighting over her isn't always fun he
kisses her in order to make her believe
that he's sincerely interested in her
but it's all part of the plan despite
the fact that Trina clearly has a crush
on Beck which doesn't go away after this
episode the feeling is not mutual and
nothing beyond friendship grows between
them after the bad bad breakup Beck and
Tori clearly have feelings for each
other which come out somewhat in the
episode Tori goes platinum Tori wins a
contest which earns her the privilege of
opening at the Platinum Music Awards but
things go wrong when she refuses to play
along with Mason's makeover and Jade
gets the role instead back in Tori alma
shares smooch before being interrupted
but the second time they come close to
locking lips Tori is the one who hits
the brakes much to the surprise of Beck
and bori fans everywhere then why can't
we just Jade
her ex-boyfriend I can't do that to a
friend Welbeck clearly isn't feeling any
loyalty to his ex-girlfriend at the
moment where he just can't say the same
although she and Jayde haven't exactly
been besties Torrey considers her a
friend and felt wrong making a move on
her eggs Torrey misses out on kissing
Beck
but Jayde gives her back her role in the
Platinum Music Awards after being
touched by her kindness in the blonde
squad cat Jada and Tori find out that
the blondes don't always have more fun
cat meets a cute guy named Evan Smith
who ends up having an issue with her
hair color but I'm really into blondes
later despite the fact that Kats upset
over another guy
Robbie digs his feelings for her crystal
clear between the words I think that
Evan guy is really dumb for not seeing
how great you are and the fact that he
serenades her with I think you're swell
I love you like a cop's marathon on TV I
love you more than the original Star
Wars trilogy Jade's jealousy was a major
issue regarding her relationship with
Beck and as we saw over and over again
even her friends grew tired of it but
during their time apart Jade was forced
to confront her feelings and realize
that her efforts to keep that close were
just pushing him away
in the episode opposite date Beck and
Tori agreed to go with a group but when
Andre and Robbie dropped out Tori had
some concerns if it's just the two of us
and it's like a date so they decided to
make it the opposite of a date by not
dressing nicely eating bad food and not
having any fun
see you at 7:00 I'm not looking forward
to it but of course they end up having a
nice time anyway even when Jade shows up
back in Tori prepare for the worst bye
surprisingly I'm not mad Jade tells Beck
he can spend time with Tori or anyone
else he wants to and fans his hopes for
beckoned Tori finally getting together
we're at an all-time high
but not only do beckon Tori fail to
progress beyond their opposite date but
then we have the episode Tori fixes back
in Jade Beck is still worried about
making Jade jealous and finding her a
date is an issue due to her intimidating
personality but the plan doesn't work
out for a couple of reasons the first is
that Gilbert loses his cool and reveal
his lack of interest and the second is
that Bek realizes he isn't into Meredith
or any girls that are just too easy to
get along with I think I just like
dating a girl who you know fights back
that confesses he still has feelings for
Jade and the two of them get back
together once again I've missed you what
are you going to do about it this was
the final reconciliation of Beck and
Jade and a major disappointment for fans
holding out hope for II was ever going
to happen
even though cabbie never officially
happened either we did see them share a
super-sweet moment during the episode
1000 berry balls cat worries that Robbie
is going to ask her to the cowboy luau
not because she doesn't like him but
because she's scared of ruining their
friendship she's so nervous about the
potential of messing things up that she
goes to Jade for help who is apparently
not a cabbie fan gross don't say gross I
like Robbie when Kat finds out he's
going with Gabriela she gets jealous and
the two end up sharing a kiss at the cow
Wow anyway even if Kat runs away from
Robbie and her feelings afterwards
ariana grande promised fans via twitter
that cabbie would definitely happen in a
future episode but sadly the show wasn't
renewed and that never ended up
happening who's your favorite Victoria's
couple even if they didn't end up
together on the show share your true
pairing with us in the comments section
stay connected to us here at the things
by clicking on that subscribe button and
turning on your notifications for more
great videos thanks for watching we'll
see you again next time